what we're creating with destiny is
definitely an exploration fantasy you're
going to go back out into the Stars and
recover everything that humanity lost
after the collapse of our Golden Age now
you will be rewarded for your bravery
and by overcoming all of this action
with loot new weapons new armor the more
you defeat your enemies and complete
your missions you're going to earn
rewards that will let you upgrade your
guardian in every conceivable way one of
the ways we let you customize yourself
is through the way you project yourself
into the world in your armor and we have
a really neat progression from bass
player armor which is pretty simple to
the really exotic stuff that you get by
playing the endgame content like raids
or really high-level strikes the
difference between seeing you know a
level 5 guy in the tower and a level 23
guy is you'll notice immediately that
the level 23 eyes are wearing stuff that
you you don't even know where that came
from it's all hand crafted to look
amazing and and create jealousy
we're really happy with how Luke works
in destiny we have a private loot stream
every single aspect of the things that
you interact with in the world are
private to you that means even
ammunition when you kill an enemy
combatant he's gonna be dropping ammo
just for you he's gonna be dropping loot
just for you so if we're gonna fire team
together it's great we're never we're
never fighting over those things and it
breathes sort of new life into the loot
system so we want every Guardian in
destiny to feel equipped with the tools
of the trade that they'll need to kick
alien ass and to survive these dangerous
encounters so there's a three weapon
system that does not mean that we have
three different weapons and destiny
think of them more as categories where
you can find all different sorts of
armaments so your primary weapon would
be your rifle or your hand cannon there
would be the special weapon maybe your
holdout shotgun sniper rifle or a
diffusion rifle and then the heavy
weapon my personal favorite category
things like rocket launchers and belt
that heavy machine guns and of course
the best part is once you form a
relationship with your favorite weapon
you can use that with any character that
you create in destiny the Arsenal is
open to every class of player see you a
hunter a warlock or even on tight the
thing that we take great pride in is
that each of these weapons has been
handmade by our artists here hand tuned
by our desires and our arsenal in
destiny is much bigger than what we've
had in the past and that's pretty
exciting for us
please do